again we're here at the grand canal
shops and maybe you don't have the kids
this weekend maybe they're with the
grandparents or you know with their
godparents
so you want to make it a nice romantic
kind of memorial day of weekend with the
couples right well
this is the perfect location for a date
night right right here at
the gondola oh my gosh there's no better
place or romantic than grand canal shops
for you
your family your friends husband and
wife
this we're right here in front of the
iconic grand canal
where you literally can shop window shop
by gondola throughout our entire
shopping area
yeah and also you know what you all have
some other attractions i've been to the
karaoke bar that you all have
camus you all have so many options we do
this is just a powerhouse of attractions
at grand canal shops
everything from madame tussauds and -5
ice bar for the family
to camo ultra karaoke 40 private luxury
boxes
where you can enjoy and really the
cherry on the top is
atomic saloon show by spiegelworld one
of the most iconic shows
on the strip at grand canal shops you
marry that with any of our incredible
world-class dining
and it's a date night it's a family day
it's everything you want from memorial
day weekend
and this is going to be a big week and a
lot of people they're now vaccinated
they're ready to you know get out
and enjoy the weekend we got probably
going to have a lot of people from
california or arizona or utah coming
down
but for us locals this is something for
us to enjoy too absolutely we welcome
everyone
all of our visitors from around the
united states and of course our locals
where
you can come to the venetian and park
for free take advantage of everything
that we have and
shopping dining and these incredible
experiences and attractions
for everyone family friends and you know
visitors from out of town that might be
visiting yeah definitely again options
for everybody so if you're going to have
a girls week and a guys weekend that
camo karaoke bar when i tell you about
those luxury boxes there's a theme in
every room
you all it's pretty fun so we're gonna
send it back to you guys in the studio
and again we'll show you a little bit
later on uh some other features that
the grand canal shops has here goods
good stuff bianca yeah it's so beautiful
in there it's so fantastic to be able to
go in there again alex
and explore some of the the shops that
are in there and the restaurants and the
fun stuff
and there's nothing wrong with a little
staycation for memorial day weekend yes
bianca you can hop in a gondola and go
right down the canal there to the gelato
that is the place to be